TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The recent TensorFlow
1.3 release
introduced datasets
and estimators,
two important features
that you should try out.
This post gives
you all the details
you need to do just that.
Google Play is committed to
bringing new diverse voices
to gaming.
Infinite Deviation
Games is a program
that gives game designers
from all backgrounds
the chance to pitch an
original mobile game concept
and have it developed,
published, and promoted
in partnership with Google Play.
Follow the link to
submit your mobile game
concepts by October 9.
Do you wish there were an
open-sourced Firebase playbook
app that you could use to
see real-life use cases that
also demonstrates the use of
multiple Firebase products
together?
Well, wish no longer.
Friendly Pix is here.
Head on over to the post for
the design doc, app links,
and the GitHub link.
Spotify and Google Cloud
recently worked together
to develop innovative security
tools that help organizations
protect GCP projects.
They're available in an
open source community
called Forseti Security.
And they are now open
to all GCP users.
We're excited to announce the
beta release of managed SSL
certificates at no
charge for applications
built on Google App Engine.
This service
automatically encrypts
server-to-client
communication, which
is an essential
part of safeguarding
sensitive information
over the web.
Getting started details
are on the post.
We're also excited to announce
that the first Google Cloud
Platform region in Germany
is now open for business.
You can now choose
the German region
to build applications
and store data.
Having a consolidated
and comprehensive view
of how your AdWords
account is doing
helps you spend less time
creating reports and more time
identifying new opportunities.
That's why over the
next several weeks
we're rolling out Dashboards,
a single place in AdWords where
you can bring together your most
important reports and unearth
insights about your business.
Screenshots and details
are on the post.
Please subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for joining me
for another episode
of "The Developer Show."
If you'd like to catch some
of the prior episodes you
might have missed,
click right over here.